i sold my startup for less
than what my investors had put in now
you know the way it worked you know
the team still did well and i made good
money off of it but like that's not
that's the that's not the definition of
a successful business because there's a
lot of people that have sold their
companies for a lot of money we have a
we have a handful of buddies that are
like uber rich no one knows who
they are and like even if they told you
that what they did you'd have to like
they'd have to beg to speak at a
conference whereas guys like you you've
got like the daily show reaching out to
you you've got celebrities reaching out
to you who want to like get on board
with you
and what i want to know is you can use
the example and then you how does
someone i guess i'm asking for myself
because how do you create so much of
this like brand equity uh like you guys
have
well i think in both cases it's
basically you put out you put your
thoughts on blast so you know they're
the re the real answer and by the way i
say that not to make fun of the
app i think did sell for a profit so
good good for them i'm saying i know
that i've gotten disproportionate credit
for my track record of success when in
reality like the best thing i've built
is this d2c company that i don't tell
anybody the name of that's the
profitable business that's doing eight
figures a year but like that's not
actually why people
my reputation came before that so you
know that's kind of weird right so where
does the reputation actually come from
it comes from two things one is you meet
people in real life so like you go meet
you know the investors at these
different big funds or uh ceos of
different companies
and when they're talking to you they're
making an independent
assessment of your lo your caliber
you're based on your thoughts so right
so so first it's like a hand-to-hand
combat thing you meet a bunch of people
you earn their respect one-on-one by by
you know when they're talking about some
deal they're doing or a company they're
building you you actually contribute by
adding value by pointing out things or
or giving them criticism or or giving
them feedback on what's really great um
or identifying to them other things that
are really cool and they say wow this
guy really you know i i got a lot out of
this conversation so you do that with
like 300 people and those people matter
right because they have themselves
influence and trust so for example
um
you know uh
like josh element is a is a good example
this guy was
he was early on at linkedin at facebook
at twitter at robin hood uh like earlier
sean meaning he was
he was like head of growth at a bunch of
these companies yeah yeah he's a big
deal he's been on our podcast and so
he's got you know tremendous people have
a tremendous amount of respect for him
because he's had a tremendous career
well both and i have you know on
separate occasions met you know
met with josh and we when we're talking
about our startup and whether our
startup succeeded or failed josh knows
look you're playing in the sort of like
the startup lottery startup olympics a
startup can fail and an entrepreneur can
still be really great
and if out of that conversation josh
josh walks away thinking oh this
person's really smart and then they
connect you to some other people that
they they know and those people say wow
josh thanks for the intro sean was
really great
you develop a reputation amongst people
who have a reputation so that's the
first step
through real-life interactions you
develop a reputation with people who
already have a reputation so that they
will retweet your stuff so that they
will vouch for you when you have a
project or you're doing something and
that that goes a long way in the
marketplace
uh so like for example i've had josh or
biology or different people who have
their own big following and their own
respect if they share me or they they
they say this person's great then a
whole bunch of other people just inherit
that reputation they say okay if josh
says he's great he's great if biology
says he's great such a unique way of
it's almost like
credibility hacking or something like
that but but that's the thing i think is
important is like
i'm telling you how the mechanic works
but there's the thing you can't just the
reason it's not a hack is because
your your thoughts actually have to be
interesting you have to actually hack
like you're you're a hack i just mean
like you're you're
getting the desired the the process of
getting to the desired outcome right the
second thing is we both created content
so now his tweets are mostly making fun
of people who create content and threads
and teach courses
but before that he was doing it himself
right he was he himself was saying you
know when you're building a social app
blah blah or here's how we grew inside
high schools for tbh and i why did i
respect him because he released this
this memo actually got leaked from
inside facebook oh yeah yeah yeah and
the memo basically said he was like hey
guys at facebook here's some of the
stuff we did to grow amongst teenagers
and i know facebook wants to grow
amongst teens here's some stuff we did
at tbh for example for every high school
we would create an instagram account
for it branded to the high schools it'd
be like you know
mckinley high
you know secrets
and that's the instagram account and it
would be locked and we would follow
anybody who had mckinley high in their
profile then they would follow it you
know 40 of people would follow us back
they would request to follow but we were
private we wouldn't approve anybody's
request
then at 4pm when everybody got out of
school one day we would accept all the
requests so everybody simultaneously
would get a notification about our
account so they would all go check it
out and then they would all see the link
to download the app and then they would
download the app and then we and then as
they're downloading the app they'd get
notifications that their friends are all
downloading the app today and it felt
like a big deal and that's how we hacked
distribution into high schools
i similarly have told actually a very
similar story about how we would go get
our goal was always to get half of a
high school to download our app in one
day we did it a completely different way
but i've shared that on podcasts
different places or on twitter threads
and people read that and they're like oh
this guy's smart that's a really
smart growth tactic this guy really
understands growth this guy really
understands teens this guy really
understands social and if so if you just
if i like it's that uh quote my buddy
jason hitchcock told me once he goes you
say one interesting thing i say huh
that's interesting you say two
interesting things like oh those are
interesting you say three interesting
things i say this guy's interesting
and uh that's really what you gotta do
with content is you have to if you say
three original interesting things around
one topic whether it's bitcoin or media
or
robotics or whatever
if i get three interesting things from
you i'll in my brain i will assign that
tag to you this guy's interesting worth
watching and then if other people
endorse it and say this is interesting
it goes even faster
[Music]
you